salut tout le monde deuxième vidéo
spécialement madness et après avoir
expliqué comment ça fonctionnait hier
vidéo avec midnight donc comme peuvent
si on vous met le lien qui s'affiche en
haut de cette vidéo on parle aujourd'hui
les stars c'est un peu plus notre credo
chez nous chez envergure qui va briller
dans cette machine march madness quel
joueur vous allez retrouver à la
prochaine draft qui vont être là durant
eybens et ses phases finales 'ainsi y
est et quel joueur aussi pourrait
profiter de ce moment pour essayer de
s'imposer et pour ça évidemment verano
guillou s'est vraiment battu ça va être
super leur explique comme comme tous les
ans la mi mars écoute moi aussi j'ai
grand at ça commence donc jeudi cette
histoire de march madness et pour
commencer pour poser les bases pour ceux
qui ne sont pas du tout suivi cette
année et vous êtes nombreux plus
nombreux que ceux qui seront suivis mais
mais on va essayer d'expliquer qu'ils
sont les gros prospects qui joue dans
les grosses fac on va pas on va pas être
exhaustif évidemment mais mais voilà là
n'est ce que tu peux nous donner des
membres de ton top chez pas ton top 10
15 qui sont là dans des grosses flaques
et qui pourrait donc aller assez loin
dans ce tournoi
ce n'est pas une cuve est super profond
dans les enjeux internationaux ni aux
joueurs qu'ils font pas la march madness
donc c'est assez intéressant fait donc
si on regarde dedans il ya que dans mon
dans ma loterie a que chez john sharper
jaden a redit qu'il faut pas la march
madness cdn sharks parce qu'il joue pas
avec clint jupiler on sait même pas s'il
va se présenter à la draft est à djeddah
nardi parce qu'il joue avec l'équipe
djigui night miss n'y a pas là il ya ce
duke pour le brunch ayrault et jean guy
finn il ya cet amour haine de gonzague a
atterri smith de o'byrne et jada ellie
qui joua a perdu ses quatre équipages
quatre grosses équipes qui ont de vraies
ambitions sur le tournoi je pense qu'il
ya toujours quelqu'un qui avec tahiti
washington
il ya baylor a gagné l'an dernier qui
est aussi très solide cette année que
jérémy socha de polonais kendall bornes
l'américain et puis les deux prospects
de la beetle qui diane murray a eu droit
qui vient de gagner deux tournois de
conférences et johnny davis continue qui
va un peu moins bien puisqu'il a un peu
blessé à la cheville mais deux équipes
qui ont aussi des ambitions
donc ça évidemment on va mettre tous les
liens de leurs scouting report de leur
fiche dans la description de la vidéo
mais vous pouvez aussi vous munir de
votre bac est puisque on a créé un
tournoi pour faire les bracket entre
entre francophones ça s'appelle le
bracket français vous allez sur et
lesbiennes sur vos montrent le lien dans
la description dans la vidéo mais mais
ça sera bien aussi pour suivre les
matchs up qu'on va vous vous annoncez
puisque c'est aussi pour ça qu'on fait
cette vidéo en fait
c'est parce que la march madness cette
march madness elle va aussi servir à
observer et bien des prospects qui vont
jouer les uns contre les autres des
prospects qui vont jouer contre des
prospects défensif plus fort ou
inversement des prospects défensif qui
vont essayer de stopper des profils
offensifs un peu particulier donc ça ça
va être très intéressant à évaluer du
coup on s'est dit avec alan qu'on allait
faire un top 5 alors à temps avant je
regarde quand même si t'as pas oublier
des gros des grosses voitures du doublé
jo ann john qui va jouer déjà les
mesures n qui va jouer mon fils moi je
tahri zone de lait sucré eau il valait
ce qui vient de virer son coach mais qui
ouais quand même à la march madness
kennedy trois heures pour moi j'en dors
de tennessy johnny tennessee qui 1 6 3
on a tout expliqué les aliments et qu'on
verra dans la vidéo a dit hier la vidéo
explicative viennent de gagner gagner le
tournoi de conférences effectivement et
sinon après il faut descendre un peu il
y aura sans doute au tchaï ac badji qui
va être si j'ai plus tu l'avais
mentionné ou pas non je veux
donc voilà on va vous faire un top 5 des
autopsies salé ce qu'il faut gagner six
matches pour aller au bout à faire un
top 6 des
duels ou des chocs entre équipes qu'on
attend d'eux plus pour observer des
prospects allen je te laisse commencé
alors moi j'ai commencé par
un potentiel match et qu'on peut avoir
au deuxième tour parce que
malheureusement je parle de ces
potentiels match qu'on peut avoir que l
élite eight donc en gros en quarts de
finale donc qu'il a la chance que ça
arrive et moi mais je trouve que je
pense qu'au deuxième tour on peut avoir
l ess us consignes et ça et le swiss
consignes je crois que toi et moi on
l'avait aussi noter on veut le voir
parce que alors il faudrait que johnny
davis soit 100% il a un peu de mal sur
la fin d'année sur le toit de conférence
cela fait une année incroyable moi je
m'y attendais vraiment pas parce que
quand même je l'avais vu avec team usa
si l'été dernier c'était un rôle player
voilà google et là il s'est vraiment
transformer cette année
en fait je voudrais voir contrainte
harrison parce que tu harrison cette
année en ciel profil quel profil les
deux pour ce complexe et harrison profil
3,4 sixième homme de l'année en
pesticides
est très très long qui défend les
porteurs de balle qui a défendu clinique
chandler déjà dit davison plein de super
g à lempdes williams 2-6 de wake forest
sur certains matches qui monte un peu
partout dans les big board parce que il
peut tirs à trois points il peut poser
un dribble et défensivement il est des
fondeurs à 5 ans initié et prend les
porteurs de ballon donc un peu comme
patrick williams le faisait avec le reed
hastings donc du lait c'est pas le
porteur de balle numéro un de ses porte
n'est pas le créateur du roi mais c'est
le seul cas le ballon qui navigue
beaucoup ballon moi j'aimerais bien voir
comment ça va se passer entre ces deux
là je vais pas tirer les normes quand
sur la comète qui ait ce match-là mais
voir tenue des listes face à un
tarissement ça peut être super voir s'il
peut obtenir les switch ou les choses
comme ça ça peut être super intéressant
effectivement ça va dépendre est
absolument de la
santé aussi de johnny davis est aussi
devoir cite ces deux équipes passent
premier tour
puisque c'est pas donné ni pour l'une ni
pour l'autre iowa state face à l ess you
est une bonne équipe qui a réussi à
faire des gros coup de cette saison par
moments et puis le col gates est prête
le site 14 le plus dangereux surtout
puisque consignes battre le leader
johnny davis ne sera sans doute pas à
100 % pur en tout cas pour le premier
match donc attention à l'aube 7 comme on
dit pour ma part je vais donner un duel
de grands un duel solide entre challenge
du renne et shelton grain
donc ça ça serait probablement si ça
arrive puisque là encore il faut que les
deux équipes se qualifient mais
probablement ça serait le headline
heures espionne pendant pendant
quasiment toute la journée quoi
puisqu'on a le potentiel numéro 1 de
grave face à celui qui était peut-être
que numéro 1 avant l'année ou qu'il a
été peut-être cours de l'année dernière
en tout cas déjà laine du rennes un des
meilleurs intérieurs de sa classe donc
les deux joues à l'intérieur c'est pas
forcément dit qu'ils défendront
l'encontre l'autre puisque gonzaga a un
profil un peu moins
porté sur les extérieurs notamment en
défense avec drew timide donc c'est
peut-être drout chimiques qui va se
coltiner la puissance de janan durel ce
qu'il serait intéressant c'est de voir
chat en grain confronté par exemple un
pick and roll avec jaden du renne en
menace de loeb puisque là on a tout de
suite une menace de loeb qui est
similaire à celle qui rencontrera une
biais et donc est ce qu'il va être
capable de gérer un garde qui arrive en
fait de gérer les incombe 2 que peuvent
provoquer ce genre de situations de jeu
et puis pour jaden du renne s'il est
amené à défendre sur cetto devrait
voir sa mobilité on va voir son
intelligence et puis on va voir aussi sa
constance parce que gonzaga c'est une
vague qui arrive sans cesse et le
principal défaut qu'on un des principaux
défauts de challenge et rennes c'est
manque de constance dans l'effort dans
la tension dans les dents les
interventions qu'elle soit défensives ou
offensives même s'il ya eu bel belle
amélioration au cours de l donc ça
serait vraiment extraordinaire après
boys estate qui affronte memphis
d'ailleurs même si c'est pas forcément
favori sur ce match
donc
pas donné mais si ça arrive ce sera
évidemment un match à ne pas manquer
pour tous les ce cas où tu es même pour
tous pour ceux qui veulent qu'ils
veulent voir du gros choc entre
prospects à toi pour la suite ouais ça
c'est super intéressant c'est de voir
turenne face à aux gardes de monza
gasperi volonté qui vont pénétrer que ça
on va voir comment il peut changer un
peu la taxe à gaza peut être top ensuite
j'ai potentiel thank you keep haylor à
l'élite ait donc en quarts de finale
aussi ça serait en gros la finale de
cette région là pour l'accès au finder
fort pourquoi parce que
j'aimerais voir la petite taille
washington se retrouve face à des
caennais brown t j allais me sociale
ceux des situations switch alors qu'on
sait que la taille de country qui s'est
pas la plus créative mes parents on
pourrait peut-être le devoir en
racontera face à des profils ailier
surdimensionné un petit peu et je me
voir s'ils arrivent à passer son
adversaire ou s'il reste encore dans le
levage me décale je fais un tir vous je
vais pas au cercle c'est un très beau
shooter un match up make her mais le
voir face à des ennemis social kendall
brown ou même un flottant bas pour
protéger le cercle qui est un très beau
protecteur de cercle comment est-ce que
tu est à washington s'il y en a
l'opportunité encore une fois
arrive il a été blessé comment que joey
davis qui s'est blessé à la cheville il
a eu du mal à revenir et l'art rater des
matchs derrière ça c'est vu puisque
quelque chose qui n'a pas très bien fini
l'année mais je pense que du tight à
washington s'il a son bon sens peut
faire un groupe renault en marche en
mars pardon et donc ça ça passerait par
un match super intéressant je trouve
contre les ailiers un peu grande gueule
c'est ça c'est des pauvres pour ce qu on
jamais vu branson orane sont des ailiers
hyper hyper athlétique surtout brun et
qui projette de jouer plutôt 4 presque
en nba
très grands chouchous fini les matches
en cinq mois à baylor et
ça fonctionne plutôt bien d'ailleurs
généralement pour baylor le 5 en mode
small ball
à moi et du coup
je vais je vais sans doute proposer un
os châu acb agit
de campsas
face à qui gagnent murray alors là ça
serait au sweet sixteen
donc ça serait comme ça se fasse à iowa
et iowa en pleine forme tu m'as dit
puisqu'ils ont gagné le tournoi de la
big ten qui était peut-être la
conférence la plus relevé en terme de
dante et j'étais peut-être de série 5
cette année et là il se retrouve avec un
site 5 qui est pas hyper haut par
rapport à leur état de forme donc ils
peuvent performer de fou et donc ça
serait vraiment un choc je pense à un
choc de deux joueurs expérimentés de
joueur qui brille plus tôt dans les
grands matches faut que j'aille jc + 1 3
2 3 qui a fait une année senior
extraordinaire en terme d'efficacité que
soit près du cercle ou loin du cercle et
keegan murray sait que ces
risers de cette année là je sais plus
combien il est chez lesbienne je devais
d'être au top 6 et 7 mai salle et donc
5e alors que c'est hyper rare pour un
joueur de son âge d'inventer un ange pas
donc ça veut dire que voilà il a fait
une année exceptionnelle il peut jouer 4
5 il protège le cercle maintenant il
remonte la balle il le pas trois points
il a vraiment une progression
moi j'aimerais bien le voir dans des
situations où il doit justement défendre
face à face à des joueurs qui ont un peu
d'expérience alors il en a déjà eu en
big ten mais avec face à des petits et
plus petits les plus véloces à
kansas ya
régné marceline yann
rapide et biz pourra aussi voir façade
et face à des joueurs très costauds des
intérieurs quasi nba au niveau du
gabarit genre tu habites mccormack donc
ça pourrait ça pourrait avoir cette
double intérêt et pour au climb agit
évidemment parvenir à faire la
différence face à une équipe de daiwa
qui défend bien qui peut switcher
c'est toujours intéressant et puis de
toute façon
l'intérêt principal pour moi de march
madness est quand même
quand il ya un grand match et qu'un bon
joueurs performent dans un grand match
ça veut dire qu'il a aussi déjà dans son
cerveau qu'il était un professionnel et
qui devait être présent à ce moment là
quelque chose d'intéressant mais sera
toujours intéressant à observer à toi
gonzague ajiq 2.0
si on le veut tous mais
si revoir paolo gontero çetin brent sur
le terrain 5 ça serait possible à
l'élite est donc en quart de finale il
faudrait que bon zagadou qui gagnent
trois matches pour se retrouver
pourquoi je veux le revoir je vais le
revoir parce que déjà c'était un des
meilleurs matches de saison régulière
cette année qu'on a eu franchement
c'était vraiment vraiment top sur le
voir parce que des griffin avait joué
même pas cinq ou six minutes dans le
premier match et je pense que sur
celui-là il jouera 30 minutes c'est un
peu le baromètre de duke quand il va
bien duke gagnent quand il va pas bien
du tout que a du mal et parce que base
sur le ratio terrain je passe six sept
joueurs qui je pense que j'aurais oublié
donc
bien coaché d'un côté cote chez eux
d'une manière
pas exceptionnel de l'autre mais par
moment ça va
voilà tchèque compte par l'eau ils
s'étaient affrontés il ya vu quatre ou
cinq moments où tout paulo avec driver
sur cech qui achètent avait rencontré
cube dans le tweet j'avais gagné quatre
de ses cinq duels là ce que ces gens là
ont évolué un peu depuis voilà les
revoir avoir potentiellement les deux
premiers choix d'un drop shock terrain
c'est cette
solution dépend des progrès au niveau de
banque qui rôdent sur le passing aussi
ont vu ses progrès lie pour
effectivement largement des films qui
joue beaucoup plus ça serait tout à fait
intéressant qui est ce que j'avais moi
aussi à j'avais
un match qu'on pourrait avoir d'elle dès
le deuxième tour fin dès le troisième
tour puisque le deuxième tour ça en fait
le celui qui se joue jeudi ce serait au
burn your way si
un choc de grands qu'ils s'écartent
entre
entre à zahia moblie le grand frère des
vannes moblie et
jabbari smith qui est projeté dans lui
aussi dans le top 5 voire le top 3 de
cette draft certains mettent même numéro
un mais bon c'est un 10e match maker
mais lui ignorant les batchs hot assez
bond puisque en fait santé il est
tellement efficace tellement l'ont
tellement tellement forts au niveau de
l'album à mi distance est de plus en
plus il s'écarte un mot glissé un peu le
même genre mais en un peu moins fluide
un peu moins mobiles mais peut-être qui
sait peut-être un peu plus
expérimentée et solide près près du
cercle et c'est une possibilité qui
défendent l'un sur l'autre si ça arrive
parce qu'il faut de la longueur pour
stopper japan et finalement il n'a pas
rencontré tant de est immense joueur que
ça déjà barry smith deux joueurs avec un
wings panne suffisant pour l'embêter
vraiment il y en a pas rencontrés tant
que ça donc je trouve intéressant ce
match up potentiel pour ça il va falloir
que you'll see se débarrasse de miami ou
mia mia qui est une équipe vraiment
dents de scie quoi
de vieux ils ont tous grandi à 30
c'est toujours
la différence c'est toujours dangereux
et o'byrne attention quand même même si
bon enfin ils sont ils sont entièrement
bien ces derniers temps mais
jacksonville state c'est pas gagné non
plus n'est pas la pire équipe des
petites équipes je t'avoue que j'ai vu
juste leur finale
qu'ils ont perdu d'ailleurs ils sont là
par défaut mais
met donc c'est ça va être intéressant de
voir jabbari smith asa et mobilis si
jamais ça arrive quel est ton prochain
c'est un match qui arrivera jamais je
pense mais au jeu comme apparaissent à
ce récit on avait tennessee town hall à
l'élite ait parce que ça permettrait de
voir john leur rencontre et 1 contre en
cas d'arrivée chemin je pense cada est
richement des poètes sur les extérieurs
des défenseurs les plus
impressionnants mois que j'ai vu en
on le voyait déjà les derniers hommes à
syracuse dans la zone où ils faisaient
des stocks sont incroyables et
superlight cependant cette année il
prend un contre un tous les meneurs
adverses sans ambiguïté leur fait vivre
un enfer il va mieux offensivement que
de plus en plus debian été assez
compliqué et quelques chants de leurs
basses et c'est un petit meneur mais
très rapide sur le premier pas qui va au
cercle qui est assez verticale qui est
très bon dans drive in teak je pense que
tennessee
a été pas super récompense est qu'un
site trois ils font très bonne saison et
gagne le tournoi de d66 peut-être qu
avoir un site 2 ou quelque chose comme
ça ça a pu permettre de les voir contre
compris seaton rôle plus tôt mais voilà
si jamais ça peut se faire qu'à d'arrêt
reichmann sur quai de chandler voir
commenter une chandler cette base la
longueur du boa constrictor qui est
kader irish monde sait s'il ya ce match
là je vais jouer mais ça arrivera pas
chance ça va être difficile je vais
rester dans cette partie de tableau la
partie de tableau ça offre et je pense
que ça peut arriver mais si ça arrive
celui que je dis le terran n'arrivera
pas du tout puisque je je je propose 1 1
arizona face à this is you dont qui joue
considère le premier tour est en fait tu
as this you tu parlais tout à l'heure de
l'équipe
u19 américaine il ya mike miles qui
faisait partie de cette équipe qui était
même dans le cinq qui me semble un
meurtre et une heure et et qui
dernièrement a sorti des grosses grosses
perfs face à des grosses grosses équipes
de sa conférence c'est pas un joueur que
les puristes du poste de meneur vont
probablement apprécié voir évoluer mais
moi je me dis que c'est un profil
typique pour briller à la march madness
dans ce genre de mec qui peut exploser
qui peut mettre quarante points dans un
match et face à arizona bah ça permettra
de voir dalle et eric un super rôle
player potentiel défendre sur myspace et
sera probablement lui d'ailleurs qui
défendra sur mac miles mais parfois il y
aura ben mathurin va falloir qu'ils se
sortent un peu les doigts en défense si
le défenseur mike mikes mais il a le
potentiel pour le faire
et donc pour moi hyper intéressant et du
coup ça pourrait on en parlera dans la
deuxième partie mais donner à miles
l'occasion d'exploser vraiment et de
faire monter sa cote de fou si ce genre
de match arrive un peu à l'époque comme
même s'il avait déjà la cote mais carson
edwards avait explosé face à virginia
qui nous
tient prêt à l'époque quand il était à
purdue
donc voilà ça c'est un potentiel pareil
match de deuxième tour on considère que
arizona devrait ne pas trop avoir de mal
face aussi de 16 qui sortira vainqueur
de cette petite fille ou
c'est un all this you ça reste très
indécis puisque ces huit conteneurs
c'est compliqué il te reste quoi comme
matchups quittant adresse il me restait
un seul et meurent est elle de lidl
malakai brain and control la défense aux
cuisses super développer de loyola
chicago c'est un peu leur dire mais ça
c'est hipster on est là c'est totalement
hipster mais le noyage chicago l'an
dernier qui avait donc à trois ans je
crois il voit en finale non ils vont là
ils vont final four l'année dernière il
bat un premier side qui est lé dinh hoa
cette année ils vont jouer au yoyo state
le premier tour s'ils ont su permet
d'organiser communique très bien et
efrim fautes 10 des fonds avec plein de
type de schéma différent face à orienter
toute mon âme à la calabre et nam est
typiquement le jouet peut être josh
primo de cette année c'est à dire le
joueur que personne n'attend super roo
dans la draft mais que les équipes le
rendent plus un an plus tôt plutôt que
de le rater un an trop tard et donc mais
il a des soucis de défense y communique
mal dit fait un peu défaut un peu
n'importe quoi je pense que le voir dans
ce match là est ce que c'est ce qui va
et ce qui est totalement perdue est ce
que l'om chicago arrive à trouver à le
mettre dans des situations où on voit
vraiment qu'il est que c'est un peu
cataclysmique ça de son appréhension du
jeu voilà c'est un désir et suspense est
le seul qui varient luxe au premier tour
donc pour ça que j'ai regardé ce match
là
parfait je vais terminer avec le côté de
kentuky toi tu voulais voir taille
taille face aux joueurs de baylor
j'avais deux autres matchs intéressants
dans cette partie avec concerné 1 baylor
et l'autre
kentucky lembeye lorsque ce serait face
dès le deuxième tour à north carolina ce
serait quand même intéressant de voir
caler blog comme tu l'as dit avec tahiti
washington face aux aux ailiers qui
peuvent switcher de baylor ce serait
aussi intéressant de voir si
sera ne peut jouer un small ball five
face à des joueurs qui sont très forts
au bon sens yves normand de cocottes
et de l'autre côté et kentucky pourrait
affronter donc s'ils sortent de
l'ornière
cs ou fullerton
et ensuite du vainqueur de michigan
state
ça ça non c est ce que vous leur temps
c'est dur pendant 5 liturgie de saint
peter's des frères drame est incroyable
kentucky et après il joue quand tu meurs
estate ou san francisco
ça c'est pas gagné
maintenant ça sent un peu l'obsède d'air
est bon
se retrouver face a peur d'y
perdre you can't you qui ça nous donne
quand même jada naïve face à oscar che
bouée en switch très violent williams
face à oscar chebbi au poste jacques
viguier zaki 10 face à un duel de gros à
l'intérieur des duel athlétique à
l'extérieur
ça serait hyper hyper intéressant je
pense pas que ce serait un très beau
match mais ça serait vraiment très
intéressant et donc donc j'aimerais bien
voir ça même si je suis un peu sceptique
évidemment sûr parce que c'est une
partie de tableau qui est dans ce même
même pour pour choeur dieu c'est pas
facile et experte génialement moi c'est
la pelure du plus dur des quatre régions
cela ouais ouais d'accord avec toi moi
sinon ça aurait été celle de kansas mais
vu que johnny davis est un peu blessé
ouais
voilà on a fini pour cette partie on a
décidé de terminer cette vidéo avec les
candidats les candidats à l'explosion
voilà donc que j'ai déjà cité might
miles toi tu as cité le joueur de s être
branham madame
donc est ce que tu as d'autres candidats
des joueurs qui voient la probable
pourrait profiter de la manne est ce
pour
pour exploser pour me faire monter leur
cote et puisque tu peux nous les décrire
rapidement
je dirais que l'une gillespie parce que
coline qui laisse pisser donc le meneur
de vilanova i la été privés de march
madness avec le co vide et ils vont
revenir et les revenus l'an dernier est
resté pour une année de plus c'est
typiquement le genre de joueur qui va
être mis en avant par le collectif 2d
des wildcats donc s'ils vont loin je
pense que c'est ce qu ils ne guérissent
piora fait des bons choix aura mis des
gros tirs tout jeune ce trotteur parce
que si loin à gaveau au final fort voire
gagne c'est parce qu'il aura défendu
fort aux ailes et mythes de votre auront
donc se profile depuis wendy en 2e année
qui plaide généralement je trouve va
s'en est vu que
renforcer d'alain terry temps à parler
je pense que lui là on l'a joué déjà
dans le tour n'a pas que toile avec
arizona il a été super important avec la
blessure de care crise a en plus
l'estonien donc il doit encore plus un
rôle à jouer sinon j'ai d'autres noms
comme qui élevait à l'oumma gignat tech
qui a été très bon dans le tournoi le
tournoi ici si abou qui gobent poésie
state mais ça voudrait dire que ça nous
nous empêche d'avoir dur n est pas ce
que c'est dire que beau résister de pas
très magnifie ce qui en hélice à la vava
jure que manu adore par exemple je pense
que c'est peut-être le mur grosse panure
prospère mais là le meilleur joueur sur
l'ensemble de la saison 2 d'alabama
était d'une brawn le reste est un de mes
joueurs préférés parce que c'est un
shooter incroyable je pense qu'ils
peuvent totalement prendre feu dans la
march madness en fait il ya deux genres
de profil il ya un peu ceux qui sont
dans les grosses équipes mais sondés
second troisième couteau et qui vont
profiter de la lumière en allant loin si
ça se trouve en ayant la tension des
défenses pour en ayant l'intention des
défenses sur les autres pardon pour
peut-être exploser un peu plus donc moi
dans ce genre là j'avais alors lui les
plus première option offensive mais vu
que c'est un collectif très huilé
j'avais tube ellis
de le lituanien de arizona ça joue très
très bien au basket
c'est grand trail complet offensivement
alors ça ressemble pas un profil de nba
mais on en a vu des joueurs qui arrivent
en nba parce que quand tu as du ballon à
ce point quand tu quand tu peut
écarter la tacc par par ta capacité à
tirer par par ta capacité à passer par
ton intelligence de jeu le fait de pas
stopper la balle quand elle arrive dans
tes mains il suffit qu'il fasse illusion
une bonne illusion en défense
justement face à des joueurs que je
parlais de might miles tout à l'heure
mais voilà ça c'est des joueurs un peu
explosifs etc qui montre qu'il peut être
intelligent de ce côté là et ça et ça
pourrait être très très très très
solide pour sa côte du belize qui est à
peine dans les top 100 il espère
donc ça serait vraiment une belle
surprise dans le même genre à kansas g
christiane brun qui lui est déjà dans
les tops complètement mais christiane
brand c'est un peu le
sidekick avec jay leno edison aussi
qu'il fait une bonne deuxième partie de
saison mais le sidekick de au child agit
donc ses neurones c'est un poste 3 il
est c'est un mec qui a l'air pâte
l'éthique et qui est très athlétique
vraiment vraiment ça saute haut il peut
mettre des grands grands dunks et 16
trous mais il va être dans l'eure le la
vidéo one shining momint parce qu'il
aura mis un gros push back sur sur la
tête de d'un joueur adverse donc
attention à christiane brand qui est
également très adroit de loin qui est
bon en défense donc donc ici se cache
pas dans les gros matchs ça peut être
évidemment très intéressant
et j'avais aussi évidemment qu'elle en
grade i qui est un favori aussi
qui est un joueur très vieux de 3 23 24
ans 24 ans et 5 mois il déjà très vieux
mais en même temps il est déjà dans un
rôle et un article que tu as écrit
question notre site sur quels ingrats
dit
qu'on va mettre aussi dans la
description
qui va être voilà dans un rôle de
shooteur spécialistes mais mais si ça se
passe bien pour kentuky ça veut dire que
kellan grady or à filocher et 6ème lundi
filoche il aura l'attention de skype
défense nba et puis après le deuxième
genre de profil c'est lé profil bas si
ça se passe bien pour ses plus petites
équipes ça veut dire que eux auront bien
joué
donc moi j'avais young chun li
complètement je l'avais aussi de
davidson qui est pareil plus tous un
shooter spécialistes mais qui en plus
est plus grand que incarne grady par
exemple fait que ce genre de profil
qu'internet h mon âme bien c'est que ben
là dans son top 33 de notre big board
donc il ya déjà certains certains
hipster comme ben dans la saison et on
était chauds sur lui
david hypatie un peu delà de la saison
davidson mais c'est quand même
intéressant j'avais tyler bertone qui
joue à richmond est un peu dans le même
moule d'ailleurs la même la même
conférence a régné de richmond voilà les
araignées de whitman les spiders comme
un meneur hyper intéressant pour
l'europe dzeko gilliam milliards d'euros
mais taylor burton lui c'est un mec qui
grand alès qui défend qui est là dans
les aides et qui a une très très bonne
patte gauche sa dégaine très vite est
capable de shooter après plusieurs
mouvements différents et également
d'aller d'aller un peu vers le service
pas mal et après mon choix vraiment du
hipster quand même c'est new mexico
state aux purées et j'étais dit allen
un mètre 98 101 kg
et cette saison c'est alors il a que 33
% à 3 points mais si je suis l'an shoot
quasi 7 par match donc on aime bien le
volume et 80 7 % ces francs
alors c'est un red shirt
junior je crois il est déjà un peu vieux
mais il avec 19 points 7 rebonds 3
passes de moyenne
un joueur solide du côté de new mexico
state qui peut faire la surprise c'est
pour ça que je parle de lui aussi c'est
parce que c'est une équipe qui peut
faire la surprise en a parlé dans la
vidéo
présentation de la march madness avec
avec hugo de minato campos le premier
tour face à yukon peut être une surprise
peut être un 9 7 et s'il y avait
peut-être teddy allen pourrait
effectivement sortir son épingle du jeu
en tant que c'est ce genre de profil de
mecs un peu con la bonne taille nba tu
vois un mètre quatre-vingt dix-huit déjà
un gros gabarit qui peuvent shooter qui
savent un peu tout faire sur le terrain
qui peuvent défendre gros rebondeur
c'est important aussi
dit que ça peut faire monter sa cote
complètement david rodier aussi colorado
insolite alors lui il a déjà pas mal
monté mais effectivement tout cela pas
mal monté mais ouais c'est jusqu'à ta
bien définis tu allais talent et les
costa ou les porteurs d'eau des gosses
de kip août à l'est et one man show les
dégâts des petites équipes qui vont être
là pour mettre des points prendre feu
voilà mais c'est une image aux fans donc
celle elle diffuse david roddick l'an
dernier 12 m l'an dernier ouais ça moi
j'avais des douzaines aussi puisque ce à
quoi tu allais pas si haute que ça et il
est capable de mettre 25 points par
match nantes 3 0 complètement refaire
refaire ce qu'il a fait l'an dernier et
jake hess dans son équipe ou joyce
maynard
je suis en or
du côté de ucla ya pas mal de candidats
ça juste david roadie donc colorado
state pour préciser il joue conte
michigan pour le premier match de moussa
diabaté
michigan qui a beaucoup de mal cette
année donc s'ils passent déjà un tour
sera énorme
mais c'est une jupe c'est le genre
d'équipé qui aime bien mois de mars
quand même s'ils gagnent donc 4e à
l'année ce que tu as un final fort déjà
ce que j'ai une ombre et gilles gaubert
ouais je les fais j'ai gonflé gonzaga
parisot n'a en finale déjà
bien et dans les autres régions je dois
je devais avoir
attends je vais checker sur
l'application mais chez que j'ai arizona
qui gagnent contre gonzague a au bout ah
ouais gonzaga perd encore la finale aux
multiples en finale avec ben mathurin
most outstanding player ou quoi
ouais ouais ça sera si certains acquis
guen fera belle match je pense si leurs
amis peuvent aller 22 23 points soit sur
la compétition je pense aux agrès ucla
parizeau n'a au burn
pas mal pas mal en obsède chez virginia
tech est riche monde qui vont à la
literie tu allais me calme
j'essaie de 30 foot est riche cette
année géniale c'est beau
virginia tech qui sort d'une victoire au
tournoi est ici donc c'est vrai que si
on suit la demande est un des meilleurs
coaches du pays en plus ouais ça mike
lee yang ça va aller loin bon vous avez
les clés vous avez les liens dans la
description et on vous donne rendez vous
jeudi à peu près en même temps que le
début des matches on va débuter un live
donc ce jeudi là le 17 on fait un live
en direct sur notre chaîne youtube voilà
il y aura alan tu sera la leur à rémire
version normalement avec bing qui
diffuse un match par jour donc il va un
peu nous détailler le programme
et puis nous dire sur quoi ça va sur
quoi vont pouvoir se régaler les fans
des abonnés de billets ce qui regarde
turbines en france sinon vous pouvez
regarder sur liliane player en replay
sur youtube aussi on vous a donné les
astuces déjà dans la vidéo d'hier et
puis évidemment si vous avez des
interrogations sur un joueur qui vous
tape dans l'oeil pendant la messe
envergure tac recherche vous tapez le
nom on a plus
4500 figés durant sa fiche c'est sûr il
y aura sa fiche exactement alan la plus
pour le live à jeudi et bon first for
déjà tour mons hainaut